puis la barre on peut la référence
ultime
j'avais pas soutenir comme ça ne
deux films sont en rade un sujet
universel parce que ça parle même d'un
plein de gens c'est à dire que on a tous
autour de nous
un très fort de caractère comme la
radinerie d'attitude et de deux
vis-à-vis des autres à vis à vis du
monde vient de la société vis-à-vis de
ses voisins vite c'est de son ex copine
et de sa fille ces choses là c'est des
choses assez assez franche et le brutal
qui sont pas difficiles à jouer et je
veux faire un chèque mais flash est à
chaque 2 2 on est tous
on est tous leurs annales quelqu'un en
fait
ce qui me fait un total de 12 euros et
90 centimes
ah non moi j'ai 12 euros 85 centièmes on
n'a qu'à tours compte et non c'est plus
prudent aller tromper ça va ça arrive à
tout le monde de se tromper et oui voilà
les gens sont incroyables fin 2006 tu es
toujours aussi radin non pas du tout je
te rappelle que tu m'a largué la veille
de mon anniversaire pour pas m'offrir de
cadeaux une coiffe il entre comme j sur
mon compte du chat 248 1596 eux passés
ces conneries vous faites déjà des
économies
je peux faire mieux d'ailleurs dès votre
bus ex-compagne en impôts locaux je le
prendrais quand ce sera gratuit
ça vous dirait d'aller voir la wii
qui m'a invité à dîner non bah quoi
quand même et oublie pas tarder à le
doubler
une assiette depuis le petit peu trop
une assiette ou les fêtes à l'unité du
boulot je suis votre fille
pourquoi tu m'a rien dit je voulais que
lui discours que son père est la plus
grande pince du monde
je ne peux pas vous loger 100 euros par
semaine c'est gentil mais quand même
donc tu serais pas un peu un peu quoi
pas un écolo un peu oui
pourquoi le départ comme ça qu'est ce
qu'elle veut être simplement apprendre à
mieux vous connaître
peut être quand même bien naïf un pour
un banquet rookie demandé ces dix ans
mais je cada bon c'est pas grave je me
relâche et vous vous connaissez panne de
gmail